[Music]
all right what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome back to another ask mkbhd video
this is number 35. it's been a little
while since i did one we did one every
month of the past two years or so we got
a whole bunch of ask mkbhd episodes in
and now took a little break from it but
i'm deciding to bring it back and we're
doing a little something different this
time i asked on twitter what you guys
wanted to know but i also asked if you
could submit video questions i figured
we'd try that out and it turned out to
work out pretty well in fact it was
actually trending on twitter for a short
period of time which i don't think i've
ever seen before for a q a but it
happened and now there's plenty of
questions so let's get into answering
them
[Music]
hey marquez my question for you is what
do you do with all those phones once you
get done reviewing them because you know
they all go on the infamous drawer never
to be seen from i heard from again and
you know once you put your review out
your great videos which are gold
standard i don't know what do you do
with those phones do you ever give them
to friends do you ever sell them do you
just leave them in there do you ever
pull one out and use it every now and
again just want to know you know what
you do with them after they're done yeah
i generally keep a lot of phones around
probably more than you would expect so
the drawer you've seen in probably
studio tours and videos in the past i
usually keep
one and then another generation of each
phone that i review so right now we have
the galaxy s10 i still have galaxy s9s
and s9 pluses we have iphone 10s max and
iphone 10s i still have iphone 10s i
don't really usually go back too far
before that so they'll either end up
being recycled donated given away sold
etc i buy a lot of phones we don't have
to keep all of them hey marquez this is
stetson landscape in your smartphone
awards video 2018 you gave the best
budget phone award to the poco phone f1
makes sense great phone packing a lot
for 300
but you can currently get a pixel 2 for
around 256 dollars unlocked on swappa my
question for you would you go with a
brand new budget phone like a poco f1 or
would you go with a used flagship phone
like the google pixel 2
interested to hear your thoughts yeah
great question i'm glad you asked this
and this is a pretty complicated one
because it actually changes based on the
phone you're talking about but this is
an age-old question do you buy a new
budget phone for you know let's say the
dollar amounts 300 bucks or do you buy a
two or three year old flagship that has
come down in price to that budget
phone's price and i'd say the answer
really depends on what you want in a
phone you got to know what you want
that's usually the answer if you want
software updates for the next couple
years your best bet is buying a new
budget phone because that older phone is
less likely to get more software updates
if you're trying to get a great camera
you're probably going to get that out of
a high-end flagship that's come down in
price instead of buying a new budget
phone i think generally for most people
you can get more bang for your buck out
of a former flagship that's come down in
price because then you're not
sacrificing as much and what you usually
see is a worse camera and worse build
quality in budget phones that's just
where they save their money um but a lot
of people have just a great time on
either so it depends on what you want
hey i'm kpsg my name is shahid and i'm
from pakistan my question is which phone
would you pick between the galaxy fold
and huawei matrix for your personal use
of course thank you now the question
question of the hour galaxy fold which
folds inward and protects the big
folding screen or huawei mate x which
folds out but has a way cooler looking
outside i'll say this with a disclaimer
that i have not actually played with a
mate x yet some people have i've watched
videos of it but i've only actually used
the galaxy fold and so from my
experience when i see a huawei mate x it
looks way cooler and so i feel like i'd
biased towards that but then of course
we had all the the durability issues
with the galaxy fold so it's kind of
hard to say i just know i'm really
excited to get my hands on the huawei
mate x that's gonna be one that i think
changes a lot of people's minds about
foldable phones if it turns out well hi
i'm kbhd so i'm curious how do you kind
of juggle between
your life as a professional facebook
player and a youtube reviewer i'm just
curious first of all nice shirt so for
those who are new or might not know
i've been playing ultimate frisbee for a
long time and i've been playing for the
pro team in new york called new york
empire for the last two years so our
season just started a couple weeks ago
um so basically every weekend and during
practices during the week i have that
and for me the timing actually has sort
of worked out this way ever since i
started playing frisbee is mostly on
weekends like tournaments are on
weekends for the pro team games are on
weekends we have a practice during the
week at night so that's after work so as
far as overlap there isn't a whole lot
of that i've always said the toughest
decision i'd have to make would be
between like a big tech event and a big
ultimate tournament or a game or
something like that luckily that doesn't
overlap pretty much ever hey mkbhd we're
the oneplus us team coming to you live
from a very special device and we're
wondering what your expectations are for
the oneplus 7 pro
i don't think i can say that all right
serious question for you would you
rather your first born child's first
words be
hey what's up guys or remember to like
and subscribe if you want to see more
videos like this one
wow i'd be very impressed if those are
the first words that is a very serious
question though i think i would say
i would rather them i'd rather the first
words be
hey what is up guys that's fine right
that's a couple
reasonable words to string together in a
row i'd be cool with that hey mkbhd
who was your favorite youtuber back when
you started and who's your favorite now
my favorite youtuber when i started
would have to be sort of the i think the
big like the big three
of tech
og tech youtube and those were
john rettinger john four lakers soldier
knows best
mark watson and chris pirillo all of
whom are still making tech videos to
this day i have to give my inspiration
or my credit towards them because they
literally paved the way of giving the
idea that you could even make tech
videos on youtube a thing so thanks to
them for that my favorite youtuber right
now actually is probably i'm gonna guess
none of you are gonna know this is uh he
does sketches caleb city i'll link his
channel right here he just literally
does all these sketches with like
himself and his friend one or two people
but they are absolutely hilarious so go
check out his channel subscribe i'll put
a link below hey marquez here's a
question for you what would you do if
youtube suddenly ceased to exist if it
just stopped existing tomorrow what
would you personally be doing well
whoa what's the uh it's the age-old
question if you weren't a youtuber what
would you be well actually it's a little
different youtube does exist but then it
just suddenly stops existing that's a
little more dramatic um i don't really
know what i would do i guess this is the
part where i'd have to fall back on my
college education and use my business
degree and my marketing expertise to
find a way to do a job with that related
i think fun fact is
before i got into really doing a lot of
youtube or it was actually as i was
doing a lot of youtube but i was
studying business and marketing because
i kind of imagined my future career path
to be
that guy
who works at a company that works with
youtubers like i'd be that the marketing
manager of a tech company that would be
working with youtubers to send them
products and make products better so i
guess to answer your question i could
still probably do that somewhere today
um but yeah if youtube just stopped
existing pretty dramatically i also
think some other video service would
just bubble up to replace youtube and
fill in the footprints that left behind
hey marcus
you said so it's been two years since
google home and other smart speakers
have been released what's your opinion
about them two years later and do you
still use them
that's well done
well done so yes i do have a google home
i have a google home max here in the
studio and i have a google home max at
home it's not my alarm clock it's too
loud to do that but i do use it to ask
questions pretty regularly i set timers
with it i ask what the weather's going
to be pretty often with it i ask it like
the random trivia questions like how
many legs does a horse have try it
yourself it's great i think the next
sort of evolution of that that we're
going to start seeing more is screens on
them we've seen this with alexa stuff
and we're probably going to see this
rumored google home
max with a screen on it um just having a
ui for it to be able to show you stuff
is pretty cool but yeah home stuff home
assistants are definitely alive and well
what uh what do you think would be the
next biggest
piece of tech um for the next decade you
know 2000's had mp3 players 2010s and
mobile phones um what do you think is
going to be for the 2020s
hmm i hope he's not getting in trouble
for doing this video on the job at best
buy so that's a big question so this two
decades ago we had mp3 players they blew
up then this last past decade we got
mobile phones if i'm being honest i
think the next decade's probably going
to be mobile phones too and then
wearable tech will start to be more of a
big thing in the future
but i've i've been pretty firm that i
think mobile phones
this thing that we pick up and use and
then put down
is like the form factor that we're gonna
have for the near future that's just me
maybe i'm not future thinking enough but
that's the way i see it hey marcus it's
john uh with this question you might be
getting it a lot i don't know but
being that the galaxy fold has been
released when do you think apple will
begin producing or even release a
foldable iphone i'm a huge apple fan i'm
not sure if i would like to see that but
it would be really interesting what do
you think
yeah foldable iphone or foldable ipad
that's the question so i guess the way i
see it apple's always had a not always
i'll take that back they haven't always
had this but lately they've had what you
call a late mover advantage in a lot of
technologies they don't have to be first
to the bleeding edge of stuff
but when they do choose to update
something or hop on board the new tech
they know it's proven the mistakes have
been made by the first movers and they
can get it right so this is really a
perfect example of that with folding
phones the samsungs and huawei's of the
world are the first movers they're the
you know they'll call themselves the
pioneers and the innovators but that's
what they're doing they're using their
first mover advantage and their supply
chain to try to make a splash and
they'll make their mistakes and clearly
some mistakes have been made already
with them but in the near future or the
far future if apple sees that it's worth
its potential they'll swoop in and
they'll get it right in theory so how
long into the future
are folding phones like really going to
be a thing before apple decides to make
a folding iphone definitely not iphone
11 probably not iphone 12.
um i could start to see in like the next
three to five years that perhaps
starting to get tidied up and maybe
there's a foldable version of the phone
but i don't think it's going to be
anytime soon hey marquez just wanting to
know how you got started in ultimate
frisbee and how that even became an
interest for you good question i think
my origin story for ultimate might not
be the same as many others so i went to
columbia high school in new jersey
and if you know a lot about the history
of ultimate that name might sound
familiar because if you go to the
wikipedia page for ultimate frisbee and
look up where the sport was invented the
answer is in 1968 ultimate frisbee was
invented by students at columbia high
school in new jersey so the sports kind
of had a rich tradition in at that high
school and it's there's a jv team and a
varsity team so when i was in middle
school i knew that that high school had
a frisbee team and i knew i wanted to
play so i instantly when i first got
there tried out for it played on the jv
team for a bit and then graduated to the
varsity team there were always
tournaments they were always traveling
it felt like a real varsity sport even
though technically at that time it
wasn't really one so yeah for me it
started because
uh there's a rich history of it in new
jersey i think for a lot of people they
you know they pick it up in college or
they discover it in their neighborhood
or at a park or something like that but
that's my og
ultimate story it's pretty loud in the
hallway but that's where i'm going to
end it thank you for your questions i
think this was fun to do the video style
i think we'll probably do that more in
the future stay tuned on twitter for
when i ask for when we do these and you
can submit your questions there and of
course as always the links to anything i
talk about that are important or that
were in the video are below but that's
basically it thanks for watching catch
you guys the next one
peace